this caught my eye tic tac oh man it was
good this was good it was a series it
was a series of videos and
it's
a girl who works for company okay young
girl there she is
she puts up a tic-tac video
about her i'm just gonna summarize for a
second her hot boss okay i know if he's
hot there's no picture of him i was
dying to see if you could at least post
a picture for the audience so we can
gauge you know was it worth it or not so
we're gonna play video by video you've
got to see how this plays out and we're
going to talk about like is this for
real what's going on here and what would
the opinion be if this was
reversed gender roles let's take a look
[Music]
oh that you got the first one tyler did
i send you the first one i wonder if
you've got oh this is part two this is
part two
this is part two but you might not have
the first one let's see let's see if we
can get the first one
you can go back to her the first one is
her that's a third one
that's the fourth one
tyler's like missing the first one
that's the fourth one
that's the last one all right let me see
if i can get it give me a minute okay so
so bottom line is young girl right she
goes online we're gonna find it we're
gonna find it for you that's my long
list of topics that i probably left one
out
um
she goes online and she has a hot boss
okay that might be it right there i
think you were on it
is this it
no this is we watched this one
no she this is the this is the first one
here we go okay
[Music]
the boss sees her
and says is that you online
that's her me once i've met my super hot
boss she put that video up and the boss
saw it
wanted to die probably
she says it was a joke to the boss
says she'll delete it right
and then she's got a bi-weekly catch-up
that's scheduled with her so that's the
first video now the second one looks
like the first that's why you got
confused the second one says part two
okay so this is part two she puts this
video in again i don't know why she
needed to do that very confusing
and then
here's part two
casually working again
she was not fired for that they went to
a lunch together oh isn't that
interesting
she's at lunch with the boss so now
everybody's like this is playing out
like a soap opera right it's like
welcome to the days of our lives
remember days of our lives style you
probably don't know the soap operas i
used to watch that one okay then we're
like okay
so
are they dating what's happening this is
the third video he's a 10 but he's my
boss he acts cold in public and hugs me
at the end of the workday okay let's see
let's play that
look at that she's like all
oh my god she's way in love with the
boss everything going on look smiling
everything okay and then the fourth
video she's not so happy
oh wait is this the one where she's not
so happy let's see
oh we grabbed some food she goes on to
say you can play that one they worked
for a little bit on saturday later they
went for dinner the colleagues joined us
now we're like okay something's there
they're dating right
this is going look she looks all smitten
she's like oh
now obviously he's seeing all these
posted right because he saw the first
one
so i'm starting to be like hmm is this
girl just looking for clicks because how
is this all playing out okay and then
the last one look people update
everybody it's blowing up on tick tock
because people feel you know we love the
reality tv we all feel like we're like
in her life now
and then the last one is this
not me offering my hot boss help but him
choosing another colleague to do the
campaign with
so at the end of the day
she's mad because the boss i guess had
to make decision about who to the
campaign with did not choose her
okay
all right so i see this
tyler i'm going to invoke you for this
i see it first off and i'm like all
right this can't first of all can't be
real right this is just her because how
could this really play out like this
publicly you know people people know her
her friends know her and whatnot they
know where she works this would just
this would be in very poor taste for the
company right if the boss is dating now
the employee that said do you think this
is real or is this all hoax
i certainly don't think it's a hoax i
don't think these people are
particularly bright like this is gonna
get up to management this is gonna get
up to actual people that see it that can
do something about it
what is the matter with you when it does
can you please post a video because i
need to see that moment and get in there
and i want to hear voices i want to hear
that go down that meeting between her
the boss and the real senior manager
but now let's think about this for a
second immediately i sat back and i said
hmm what if it was reversed
and that was a guy
that was it was a female boss
and it was a guy who put out something
and said oh i just went and i
had you know
my my hot my hot boss and it was talking
about a female i guarantee you that
there would be like sexual harassment
thrown in his face
i don't think that's as bad okay look if
a guy does it to his boss but what if he
did it to her like what if he was the
boss
and did it to the i think that he was
well that's different because that would
then be a power dynamic right because if
it was if tyler's saying if the boss
hit on the under you know the
employee i guess we'll say i don't know
she seems like she's like just started
out
that would be bad right that would be
bad either way i think although it would
it would get more attention if it was
you know a male boss hitting on
a young girl right because that's a
power dynamic then that becomes like
sexual harassment sexual harassment they
always say is about power but i'm saying
even so
even if it was a young guy who made
these videos think about it and you have
a female boss who doesn't take well to
this
isn't complimented by it and it's like
this is inappropriate
fired i i think certainly but i actually
think i think if it was a female boss i
think she'd be i think she'd be into it
i think they'd be sleeping together
probably oh yeah is everybody sleeping
together because i think she'd know that
she was more powerful
right that she's the boss i think she'd
be into it if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
[Music]